I was still there.
I really believe cinema teaches us to see.
The way we show the world
is going to change the way we see this world,
and we live in a moment where the mass media
are doing a terrible, terrible job
at representing the world:
violence, extremists,
only spectacular events,
only simplifications of everyday life.
I think we are recording
to regain a certain complexity.
To reinvent life today,
we have to make new forms of images.
And it's very simple.
Muito obrigado.
(Applause)
Bruno Giussani: Vincent, Vincent, Vincent.
Merci. We have to prepare for the following performance,
and I have a question for you, and the question is this:
You show up in places like the ones you just have shown us,
and you are carrying a camera
and I assume that you are welcome
but you are not always absolutely welcome.
You walk into sacred rituals,
private moments in a village, a town,
a group of people.
How do you break the barrier
when you show up with a lens?
VM: I think you break it with your body,
more than with your knowledge.
That's what it taught me to travel,
to trust the memory of the body
more than the memory of the brain.
The respect is stepping forward,
not stepping backward, and I really think that
by engaging your body in the moment, in the ceremony,
in the places, people welcome you
and understand your energy.
BG: You told me that most of the videos
you have made are actually one single shot.
You don't do much editing.
I mean, you edited the ones for us
at the beginning of the sessions because of the length, etc.
Otherwise, you just go in and capture
whatever happens in front of your eyes
without much planning, and so is that the case?
It's correct?
VM: My idea is that I think that
as long as we don't cut, in a way,
as long as we let the viewer watch,
more and more viewers are going to feel closer,
are going to get closer to the moment,
to that moment and to that place.
I really think of that as a matter of respecting the viewer,
to not cut all the time from one place to another,
to just let the time go.
BG: Tell me in a few words about your new project,
"Híbridos," here in Brazil.
Just before coming to TEDGlobal, you have actually
been traveling around the country for that.
Tell us a couple of things.
VM: "Híbridos" is — I really believe Brazil,
far from the cliches, is the greatest religious country in the world,
the greatest country in terms of spirituality
and in experimentations in spiritualities.
And it's a big project I'm doing over this year,
which is researching in very different regions of Brazil,
in very different forms of cults,
and trying to understand how people live together
with spirituality nowadays.
BG: The man who is going to appear onstage momentarily,
and Vincent's going to introduce him,
is one of the subjects of one of his past videos.
When did you do a video with him?
VM: I guess four years ago,
four years in my first travel.
BG: So it was one of your first ones in Brazil.
VM: It was amongst the first ones in Brazil, yeah.
I shot the film in Recife,
in the place where he is from.
BG: So let's introduce him. Who are we waiting for?
VM: I'll just make it very short.
It's a very great honor for me to welcome onstage
one of the greatest Brazilian musicians of all time.
Please welcome Naná Vasconcelos.
BG: Naná Vasconcelos!
(Applause)
(Music)
Naná Vasconcelos: Let's go to the jungle.
(Applause)